ADRIAN LUDWIG: Hi, my
name is Adrian Ludwig.
I'm on the Android Security
Team here at Google.
And just this week, we released
our 2016 Year in Review.
And so I know that
it's a long document.
And a lot of folks won't
have the opportunity
to go through the entire thing.
So we wanted to put together
a few of the highlights,
talk through them, and give
you a little bit of perspective
on what we've seen over the
last year in Android security.
So to begin with,
what's incredible
is the continued growth
in the Android ecosystem.
And along with the growth
in the Android ecosystem,
our protections
have grown, as well.
In 2016, we grew to protect
over 1.4 billion devices out
in the ecosystem across
the entire globe.
We scan over 750
million devices per day,
so an incredibly large
investment in checking what's
going on in the ecosystem,
and understanding, both
the protections that
we have in place,
but also the risks that
users are being exposed to.
One of the most
important characteristics
of the Android ecosystem is how
we've committed to being open.
And from a security standpoint,
that's incredibly valuable.
It gives us the ability
to tap into the collective
intelligence around
the world that's
invested in protecting the
Android ecosystem, users,
devices, and applications.
So you don't have to rely just
on Google, just on OEMs, just
on carriers, you can rely,
really, on the entire world,
and its commitment
to protecting itself.
And that's something that's
unique about the way we've
designed our ecosystem,
is the ability
to bring in that
collective intelligence.
To facilitate that
intelligence, and make sure
that the best things
are being done,
it's really important that
there be data, that there
be transparency into
what's happening
in the ecosystem, the direction,
and the types of threats
that users are being exposed to.
So this Year in
Review report is just
one example of the
type of transparency
that we're trying
to provide, and make
sure it's pervasive across
the entire ecosystem.
Openness also means choice.
It means that you
can look at the data,
understand what's going
on in the ecosystem,
and make decisions
about how you interact
with your device, about what
type of device you select,
about where you install
applications from.
So all of this is designed
to make it possible for users
to do the right thing
for themselves as they're
interacting with the
rest of the world
through the Android ecosystem.
And the reflection of that
is the incredible types
of experiences that
were being built.
And these were experiences
that depend, at their core,
on the security of
their devices, things
as simple as games, where the
integrity of the operating
system is critical to the
functioning of game play.
Things like ride
sharing, or other sort
of social mechanisms for
consummating transactions,
Uber, Lyft, and all of the
other types of applications
that have been built
on top of the Android
platform and other
mobile platforms,
depend upon the security
of those environments.
Some of the most
exciting examples
of how we're seeing
Android and mobile devices
transform how people
interact with the world
are at the high
end, where payments
are becoming easier and
easier on mobile devices,
because of the integrity and
security of these operating
systems.
And even at the very
extreme high end,
you see users who
are potentially
some of the most significant
targets in the world--
state leaders, national
leaders, international leaders--
who are able to use the openness
and flexibility of Android
to build very secure
capabilities that
haven't been possible on
closed systems in the past.
For me, personally, one of the
things that's most exciting
is that Android has
facilitated low-end devices
being more secure.
So for users who aren't able
to commit hundreds of dollars
or even thousands of dollars
to protect themselves,
they still get
out-of-the-box protection.
And that's one of the
things that I'm personally
very committed to, and
the team around me,
and Google are
very committed to,
as well-- making
sure that everybody
in the world, our
billions of users,
have access to the best security
protections that are available,
so they can go about their
lives in knowing and having
confidence in their
mobile device.
So that's sort of
how we approach it
from a strategic standpoint.
When we look at
a single year, we
begin to see what the
trend lines look like.
And so I wanted to hit a few
of the highlights that are
included in the annual report.
It's about 75 pages long, so
you may not have an opportunity
to read the entire thing.
But here are some
of the takeaways
that you can probably hang onto,
and think about over the coming
year.
The first is the expansion
of the protections
that we have that are
service-based in the ecosystem,
so actively checking and
improving the consumer
developer enterprise protections
to make sure that users have
the best environment possible.
So a big investment in
those kinds of capabilities.
We've also invested quite a
bit in the platform security.
When I talk about
the platform, I
mean the open source technology
that's delivered on all Android
devices.
So we've enhanced it with
key security technologies,
greater adoption of encryption,
greater adoption of Smart Lock.
We'll talk through
some of the trends
that we've seen
over the last year
as we go through
more of the content.
One of the most
significant changes in 2016
was that we transitioned towards
having monthly security update,
including security fixes that
have been found by the security
community outside of the Google,
as well as our researchers here
at Google.
We had 12 security updates
on a monthly basis.
And we're going to continue
that going into 2017--
a very significant
adoption of those
by OEMs across the
entire Android ecosystem.
One of the hallmarks of our Year
in Review is a focus on data,
and looking at what's actually
happening in the ecosystem.
And so there are
a few measurements
that we're going to call out.
And I'll sort of
walk through them
as we go through
this presentation.
But they go really
into great detail
in the written out form
of the annual report.
Some of those data are around
malware and the distribution
of malware.
2016, relatively flat.
Very slight declines in the
overall number of devices
that have malware installed
from what we saw in 2015.
On a category-by-category
basis, whether devices
were in Play or outside of
Play, we saw those declines.
And one of the
highlights, for me,
was that 50 out at the top
50 most populous countries,
in terms of number of
devices that they have that
are downloading
applications, saw a decline
in the rates of malware
getting onto those devices.
So incredible progress that
we've made in protecting
Android users across
the Android ecosystem.
And then since there was a lot
of news about Android security,
as has been the case for
the last several years,
we'll flag a couple of the
most prominent stories,
and talk through where those
stories went after they hit
their peak in the headlines,
and then how they declined
throughout the
year, as protections
have kicked into
place, and made sure
the users ended up
in a safe place.
So we're going to walk through
three different primary areas,
the robust platform,
services, and updates,
and talk through the changes
that happened in 2016.
So here we go.
Let's take a look
at the platform.
At this point,
Android has delivered
on most of the major security
capabilities that are expected
of any mobile platform.
We have strong integrity
through verified boot
going up through
the entire stack.
It's tied to a hardware
route of trust.
Encryption has been enabled
for two major releases.
And so we've begun to
see substantial adoption
of encryption across
the Android ecosystem.
So there were a number
of significant features
that were delivered in 2016.
But one of the most
important characteristics
of these features is not
the technology itself,
but the rate at which
it was being picked up,
And the rate at which we're
able to deliver new security
technology into the platform.
So this is a graph that's
included in the report.
It talks about the fact
that, even though encryption
of full-disk encryption was
enabled all the way almost four
or five years ago in the Android
platform, prior to Android 5.1,
there was practically
no adoption of it.
It was there.
Users just didn't turn it on.
And so we saw adoption
that was less than 1%.
It became required for new
devices with Android 6.0.
And with Android 7.0 we
saw continued acceleration.
So we went from
1%, to 20%, to 80%.
And we're expecting
that that will continue
to grow until we achieve,
over the next couple of years,
nearly 100% adoption of
encryption across the Android
ecosystem.
So that, I think, is one of the
most important stories of 2016,
in terms of features,
is recognizing
that these features are
able to achieve velocity
and adoption very, very quickly,
which is really exciting.
Here's another feature.
This one, there
were changes in how
users interact with the
feature, but not as substantial
as one encryption.
And so we saw adoption of
Smart Lock go up by over 175%.
So the story here is
really understanding
that the features that are being
released are being picked up
and being used
very, very quickly.
And so when we look at the core
platform capabilities, the fact
that all of the major
features are in place,
and we're now starting to enter
a phase of incrementalism,
in terms of the features
that are being introduced
into Android, I
think we're actually
in a really exciting place
for getting these features out
to as many users as possible.
It also makes it possible for
us to focus on the details,
really invest in individual
security researchers
expanding the number of
people who are finding issues
and reporting on them.
So one of the areas that we've
been investing a lot in 2016
is in our Security
Rewards program.
The way this program works
is anybody in the world
can become a security
researcher focused on Android.
All they have to do is find
issues and report them to us.
One of the really
fascinating characteristics
that we've seen of the
Security Rewards program
is who it is that it draws in.
Areas of the world that
previously have not
been significantly involved in
providing independent security
research have really
flourished on Android.
So areas of China,
Eastern Europe,
and a number of other
places around the world
that previously hadn't
had a significant amount
of public open security
research have really
been contributing
a lot to Android,
to the tune of over 100
different contributors
around the world, and over
a million dollars invested
in finding and fixing security
issues on the Android platform.
So that's where
we've been investing
in the platform itself.
The other area that
we've been investing in
is in comprehensive services.
These are the
services that we use
to help monitor the ecosystem
and react in near real time
to issues that might be found.
So let's talk through some
of those capabilities.
As you may recall from
last year's Year in Review,
or if you've been
looking closely
at what we're doing
in Android security,
there's four different
areas that we're
investing in services.
The first is around
analyzing applications.
I'll talk more about
that in just a second.
We call that Verify Apps.
The second is what we refer
to as the Sensor Network,
or sometimes we talk
about it as SafetyNET.
This is looking at
non-application based signals
on a device to try to find
potential security risks.
So we're analyzing
whether devices
might be being exploited in
the browser, whether they might
be running into
network problems,
or any other type of issue
that has security significance.
The third thing
that we invest in
is protections for
lost or stolen devices.
It continues to be the case that
the largest threat that most
users face is a potential
loss of the device,
where not only is their
data exposed to risk,
but they also are
potentially losing
the significant
financial investment
that they've made
in what may be one
of their most important
and valued possessions.
And so Android Device
Manager is designed
to help users lock or find
a stolen or lost device.
The fourth area that's a pillar
for our security services
is APIs, recognizing that
Google has built these services,
made them available
to consumers,
but that there are
application developers that
might want to take
advantage of them, as well.
So APIs is an area that we've
invested in significantly.
And the report goes into a
number of different examples
of the types of APIs.
I'll talk about just one today.
The application review
process continues
to be one of the most
high-profile and significant
services that we have
available within Google
services for Android.
It plays two
different functions.
The first function
is to make sure
that any application that
gets uploaded to Google Play
has gone through a
comprehensive security review.
That means dynamic analysis,
looking at signatures,
third-party reports, having an
integrated approach to handling
security reports from other
security solution providers,
anti-virus companies, et cetera.
It also means that we pull in
data from the SafetyNET sensor
network to see what's actually
happening out on the ecosystem,
so that we can actually
incorporate that
into assessing whether
an application is
safe to be on Google Play.
So that's one
function that we play.
The other is to
provide a protection
for applications being installed
outside of Google Play.
And they go through exactly
the same level of scrutiny--
so very, very detailed
scrutiny-- that in many cases,
can be fully automated,
but in some cases,
ends up going to a final,
manual, human review.
So we can categorize
applications
into one of about 20 different
categories of potentially
harmful application,
or say that it's safe,
and the user can
go on and install,
and go about their business.
We constantly re-review
these applications
to see if there's
anything that's changed,
if there's new data
that's available,
or even if maybe we made
a mistake in the past.
Because these things
happen when you're
operating at the type of
scale that we're operating at,
with over six billion
applications reviewed
every single day.
So we've got a little video
of that sort of takes you
through the process
to understand
how it is that we approach it.
And let's play it here
and take a look at it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Did you know Android has
built-in anti-virus protection
that gets more
powerful every second?
It starts when an Android
developer uploads their app
to Google Play.
A self-learning
at-risk analyzer scans
and simulates perhaps looking
for potential security issues.
If there's an issue, the app
won't appear in Google Play.
On Android devices,
Verify Apps regularly
scans for harmful behavior,
warning users, and then sending
this information
to the analyzer,
so it keeps getting smarter.
SafetyNET also scans devices
for exploits and network
vulnerabilities, protecting more
than one billion devices daily,
and again, sending data
back to the analyzer
to get more powerful.
Android and Google
Play, constantly making
your mobile device
safer at home,
work, and everywhere in between.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ADRIAN LUDWIG: One of the
areas that we've significantly
increased our
investment in 2016 was
in what's called machine
learning, neural networks,
and providing artificial
intelligence as a means
to detect harmful behavior.
One of the most
interesting characteristics
that we found as we begun to
develop these new technologies
is that, often, discovery
is not about looking
for the needle in the haystack.
It's about trying to find
the effect of that needle,
or trying to see
what impact it has.
So one of the approaches
that's sort of represented here
visually is where we cluster
applications together.
So we're not necessarily looking
for the specific bad behavior
within these clusters.
But we identify
applications that
are related, based on
some characteristics,
all applications that
abuse SMS, all applications
that take advantage of
the user's credentials,
what's called phishing.
These clusters get created.
And then, in an
automated fashion,
we can detect
applications that look
similar to the other
members of a cluster,
but that haven't
been categorized.
And that accelerates
our ability to identify
potential related
applications that
wouldn't be visible to a human.
There are just too many
variables that are in there.
So we're looking at literally
hundreds of thousands
of different characteristics
of any one application,
and then trying to
see how it might
be related to millions
of other applications
that are out there
in the ecosystem.
The human brain just can't
process that sort of scale.
And so we're using machine
learning and neural networks
to build out these
kinds of capabilities.
Another investment we've made
that's at incredible scale
is a technology
called Safe Browsing.
Originally developed at
Google almost 10 years ago,
this is a protection that's been
built into most of the world's
major browsers at
this point, on most
of the world's major
platforms, so Windows, iOS,
and on Android.
And what it does
is it warns users
about potential risks
on a specific website
or HTML-based page that
they might be going to.
On Android, we've
gone one step further.
Not only is it exposed as a
capability inside the browser,
but it's also an API.
So any application can
incorporate this technology
directly, and protect
users in the context
of their application
when it might
be displaying web content.
We've seen, of course, that
there is some bad behavior
out there on the web.
And so there are
many instances where
we're flagging things
across the ecosystem,
and helping to protect
users that way.
Another area that we've been
investing in, as I mentioned,
is identifying bad
applications, and then
protecting users from them.
This graph that I'm
showing here right now--
it's described in more detail
in the full annual report--
is simultaneously one
of the most boring
and one of the most
exciting graphs.
And I think it's its boringness
that is what's telling.
For many years, there has been
a concern that at any moment
there could be an uptick
in the level of potentially
harmful applications that are
installed on Android devices.
So this graph goes back almost
three years at this point,
showing quarter by quarter how
many devices in the Android
ecosystem had a potentially
harmful application installed.
And what's interesting
about it is how flat it is.
It's how boring it is.
And that speaks to
the efforts that we've
had in place to protect
users on an ongoing basis.
Every time we see an
uptick in the line,
new protections are introduced.
Every time we see a downtick,
And so we're able to
keep it nice and stable,
even though there is very active
efforts to exploit or take
advantage of Android users,
as is to be naturally expected
that are an ecosystem of this
scale with the diversity of use
cases that Android is facing.
And so I'm I excited
that this has continued
to stay stable with
about 0.7% of Android
devices having a potentially
harmful application installed
on them in 2016.
We look both at the
number of devices
that have a potentially
harmful application installed.
We also look at the mechanism by
which these installations take
place.
And so the second graph here--
that's described in more
detail in the report--
provides an overview
of different channels
that users might install from.
If they're installing from
outside of Google Play,
we did see a decrease
in the amount of risk
that a user's exposed to.
About 9% of installations
from outside of Google Play
were potentially harmful
applications in 2015.
In 2016, we've cut that
nearly in half, to about 4.8%.
In the context of Google Play,
which is the lower line here,
we've also cut it by about 50%.
But the baseline
was a lot lower,
which gives us the
ability to make
a statement that the risks of
installing from Google Play
are about 1/10 the
risk that a user is
exposed to if they're installing
from outside of Google Play.
We're going to
continue investing
in both of these areas to make
sure that we have the best
possible protections
in Google Play,
and the best possible
protections for users
who are installing
outside of Google Play.
That's the commitment that
we've made to the ecosystem,
to maintain openness,
but also allow
for users to be safe in the
face of that kind of openness.
There's a lot more detail
there on the right hand side
and in the full report.
I'd encourage you
to go take a look
if you want to get into it.
There are a number of
other slices of the data
that are included in
the Annual Review.
One of them is
country by country.
I'm not going to dive
into the detail here.
But as I mentioned sort of the
beginning of the presentation,
of the 50 largest most populous
user bases for Android,
those countries,
every one of them
had a decline outside
of Google Play in 2016
in the overall risk that
users were exposed to
in installing applications.
So I'm very proud of
the fact that we're
seeing the ecosystem get
better at protecting itself
on a country by country basis.
We also have, inside the annual
report, a breakdown of type
of application.
So enterprises, for
example, may not
be as concerned
about SMS fraudware,
or maybe they're very concerned
about Trojans, or back doors,
or phishing of user credentials.
And so we break it down
category by category.
Most of the major categories
did see a decline, both inside
of Google Play, and on this next
graph, outside of Google Play,
as well.
So you can take a
look at the report
and get into the full
details of where and what
types of risks users
are being exposed to
and understand
what it looks like.
But to summarize it,
basically in 2016, everything
got a little bit better, which
is exciting for a security
practitioner to know that the
efforts that we're investing
are actually working.
And we're seeing users get
to a place that's safer
than it was in 2015,
'14, and sort of goes on
backwards in time.
One of the key
learnings that we've
had over the last
several years is
that just protecting
from malware
is not sufficient, that there
are use cases at an application
level, but also at a personal
level where users want
to know more about
the environment
that their applications
are running,
and how safe their
environment is.
One of the things that
was introduced in 2015
is what we call the
SafetyNET Attestation API.
This is an API that's exposed
to application developers,
whether that be an enterprise
inside of their MDM agent,
or maybe a banking
application and their direct
to consumer application.
Or one of the largest areas
of adoption we've seen
is actually in the gaming
space, where games--
which are, in some cases,
multibillion dollar businesses
on an annual run rate, and have
all of their revenue coming
from these client
devices that are
running Android, iOS, and other
mobile operating systems--
they really depend upon the
integrity of these devices.
And so some of them take
advantage of these APIs.
So because there are over
200 million instances
of the SafetyNET
Attestation API being
invoked on a daily
basis around the world,
we're able to get a good view
of the integrity of devices
around the world.
And so we go into
the annual report
and break that down sort
of country by country.
Here's a visualization.
And you can see some highlights.
In Japan, over 97% of devices
have an intact security model
that has gone through
the Google certification
process, so a very high
degree of confidence there.
It's lesser in some of the
other areas of the world.
India is an area of
the world, for example,
where the number of devices that
have gone through certification
is significantly
lower, at about 86%.
And that's an area that we're
going to be making investments
in 2017 and into the future
to make sure that we're
able to raise both the
quality and the compatibility
of these devices
around the world.
So that gives you a
sense for the services
and the protections
that we've put in place,
and how those are playing
out in the ecosystem.
The last area that I wanted to
spend some time talking about
is specifically around updates.
This has been a very substantial
area of investment for Google
over 2016, as well as for a lot
of our partners in the Android
ecosystem.
So I want to talk a
little bit about what
we've been doing in
terms of updating
both devices at the
operating system level,
but also in terms of
updating applications,
and making it possible
for developers
to be responsive to
potential security
risks in their applications.
So to start, let's
talk about devices.
It's been a really
exciting year.
2015, we introduced what was
called the Security Patch
Level, which made
it possible to track
how many devices were being
updated with security updates.
In the past, it simply
wasn't possible.
The diversity of devices
in the ecosystem,
the diversity of versions, made
it very challenging to do that.
And there were actually
security research
that was done by the
University of Cambridge
and a few other places just
to understand how many devices
were being updated.
So simply being
able to understand
was significant
progress in 2016.
Beyond that, once
we could see that,
we could see that over
half of the top 50
devices at the end of 2016 had
an available security patch.
And in fact, over half of
the devices in the Android
ecosystem, over 700
million devices,
received a security update
at some point in 2016.
So significant investment across
all of the different OEMs.
Here, we've also
highlighted a few
of the devices that are
receiving updates very, very
quickly, and are maintaining, on
an ongoing basis, a high level
of patching.
Devices coming from Google,
like the Pixel and Pixel
XL, the Moto Z
from Motorola, OPPO
on the A33W, Nexus 6P,
Nexus 5, 5x, and 6, Samsung
with the Galaxy S7--
so a wide range of
different devices
that are receiving security
updates on a regular basis.
So really exciting to
see in 2016 the ability
to actually understand
what's happening,
and great progress,
in terms of getting
devices brought up to date.
One other reason that
those security updates
are so important is because
of the active investment
that we're making in
security research.
Earlier, I talked about over 100
different security researchers
worldwide, and over
a million dollars
spent on finding
security issues,
and then resolving
those security
issues across the ecosystem.
The result of that labor was
over 600 different security
issues that were
identified, and that
were solved through
security bulletins that were
delivered on a monthly basis.
So an incredible
amount of investment,
diverse set of
perspectives and opinions
that are being brought
in that, ultimately,
make the Android ecosystem
that much more strong.
So I'm really excited to see
that level of investment being
made, and the results that we're
getting from security research
program, and the security
patches being pushed out
to Android devices.
We want to make sure that that
same level of scrutiny that's
applied at the
operating system level
can be applied at the
application level, as well.
My history, and the history of
lot of folks in the security
community, has been
to watch investments
made at the platform
level never really make it
to the applications.
And then the applications
become the weakest link.
And so with Android,
we're trying
to make sure that
that doesn't happen
by making early investments
in detecting and preventing
security vulnerabilities
at the application level.
One of the programs
that we've put in place
is what's called the Google
play Application Security
Improvements program.
This was launched in 2015.
It takes advantage of
our scanning technology
to look at applications that
are published to Google Play,
and find potential
security issues--
not bad behavior by the
application, but just
a mistake, including
an old version
of a library that's
no longer up-to-date,
mishandling a particular
type of certificate
when managing encryption
on an HTTPS connection.
So in 2016, we expanded
the scope of that program,
adding over 18 new checks
for potential security issues
in helping developers
know about the flaws that
were introduced into their
applications and correct them.
In 2017, we're going
to continue to do that.
We think this is
really important sort
of foundational technology
that's unique to Android,
but shows how we're very
committed to openness
and to helping developers
flourish on the platform.
So that openness is
a double-edged sword.
One of the things that comes
of being open, and transparent,
and encouraging security
research on the platform
is news.
And sometimes, that news
can be a little bit biting.
And so one of the things
that we want to do
is take a look back at some
of the larger stories in 2016,
talk about what's
happened, and make sure
that people recognize
how much protections
had been put in place
in direct response
to some of these issues.
So the first example of a
potentially harmful application
that received significant
attention in 2016
was named Turkish Clicker
by Check Point in research
that they published this year.
This was actually a family
that Google has been tracking--
through both Google
Play, and outside
of Google Play-- since 2014.
So it's one that we've been
monitoring for quite a while.
What was interesting
about it is that it
diversified significantly
around the world,
and had a large number
of different applications
that had been built.
So it was very actively
trying to evade detection,
both by Google, and by others
in the security
research community.
By the end of 2016, the
protections that we had built,
as well as some of the ones
that were made available
by other third parties,
had done a great job.
And basically, by
the end of 2016,
we'd seen Turkish Clicker come
to an almost complete decline.
Ghost Push was the
name of a family that
received significant attention
in the middle of 2015,
and actually, was quite
prominent in our 2015
year in review, as well.
At one point in 2015, it
represented almost half
of the overall
installs that were
taking place in the ecosystem.
It was so aggressive.
And across the entire year,
Ghost Push was about a third
of the overall potential
harmful applications
that were installed on the
Android ecosystem in 2015.
This graph in the
discussion that's
inside the Year in Review talks
about the protections that
were put in place, and the
fact that, by the end of 2016,
we basically aren't seeing
Ghost Push at all anymore.
Their efforts to
install applications
have been thwarted
through a combination
of direct intervention
by Google,
as well as intervention in
partnership with our OEM
partners, and some of the
others in the Android ecosystem,
in order to protect
the installation
of these applications
onto devices.
Another example that received
fairly large attention
was a family called HummingBad.
These applications
routed the device,
and then tried to take advantage
of third-party properties
on the web.
And that's a common
theme that you
might have seen across
the last three families,
where they're really
trying to monetize
the devices through abuse, such
as installing applications,
or going after
properties on the web.
What we didn't see
a lot of in 2016
were applications that tried
to actually access user data.
Usually, if there was
any access of user data,
it was to get
credentials to facilitate
installation of
applications, or another sort
of commercial mechanism.
But the short of it
is, for HummingBad,
identified over 24,000
unique applications,
a large number of install
attempts around the world.
But almost all of them were
outside of Google Play.
And so here was an area where
the protections in Google Play
were sufficient to
prevent all but one
instance of the application in
the HummingBad family getting
on to Google Play.
And so most of the activity
was outside of Google Play.
The clean up was successful.
And at this point, we're
seeing very few installations
of HummingBad on
to user devices.
And so to summarize, when
we're looking at potentially
harmful applications, what
we've seen consistently
is early detection via Google
Play, or by the Google efforts
to identify potential harmful
applications, researchers
in the security community
flagging or identifying
these things and generating
headlines and media interest
in them a little
bit later in 2016,
but that ultimately,
soon after that,
we see those families
begin to recede,
in terms of their
effectiveness, and the impact
that they have on users.
So the last thing that we
wanted to mention was--
I've hinted at it a few times.
The goal here was to summarize
some of the highlights
from our annual report.
There's a link-- should be
somewhere behind me, I think--
to describe where you can go to
grab the annual Year in Review.
I would encourage
you to read it.
It gets into a lot more
detail on individual families,
on individual protections
that have been introduced,
and gives you a
good sense for where
it is that we see Android
security going in 2016,
and a precursor to where it
will be going into the future.
So thank you very much.
I appreciate you
taking the time.
And have a good
rest of your day.